you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
and I just got paired up playing now a
3-2 game let's uh kick off with the
Carroll Khan and try and get our
light-square bishop outside the pawn
chain so let's take here they're going
for a gambit
I usually decline this to take or not
let's see and I'm gonna bypass it
becomes a bit awkward to develop their
Kings side now and with this move with
that move normally I would come out to
f5 but not in this case because I run
into Tempe gaining moves like g4 h4 and
I then have some concern about my bishop
let's play in the night and even think
about 95 so I'm expecting they're
thinking about queenside castle with
that that's a mysterious move hmm okay
so 95 um lets castle first
Knight d5 I'll get in at some point
maybe right now yeah why not let's go
for it
I would love they take with the bishop
ooh I get there dark square Bishop I'm
gonna take that and let's get my other
night working there's no sacrifice as
working here
I want to break at this pawn but how to
do it exactly hmm let's start with this
I need to get my light square Bishop
working next so probably just be six
Bishop b7 you know let's do that I'm not
taking on here pretty much ever because
of pawn takes and I help the rook out
and their center so let's keep the
bishop pair Bishop b7 Queen c7 and then
c5 ooh okay maybe now consider capturing
yeah let's consider capturing now that
they can't play pawn takes and open the
F file and maybe this move g6 oh yeah I
like that I'm still I still have a close
eye on sacrifices here I'm still looking
to open up the position for the two
bishops they're threatening f5 now
because of this Bishop let's probably go
here you know what this move g6 i
weakened the dark squares but I have my
dark square Bishop around to compensate
so probably Queen here protecting the
bishop enabling c5 still nothing is
going to happen on e6 I don't think at
least probably c5 you know let's go for
can end up with an isolated pawn I want
to keep the Queen's on the board I
believe mmm or do I
hmm that's a bit
we could enter an opposite color Bishop
ending pretty soon the night we'll be
making use of this square to keep the
Queen's on or not
hmm I'm going to say I'm going to say
let's let's exchange Queens so on 94 I'm
not going to take still want to play
this position with the two bishops it's
tough to really get if they're Queen
side pawns Bishop b3 is a good defender
or even b3 with any pressure with rook
b8 stuff so I'm boxing out this Knight
my bishop controls the night so I view
this I'm looking to just occupy the D
file huh well let's let's play here stop
b4 weakening b5 but okay hmm mmm take
the knight
no let's get to the open file
threatening to maybe take and then play
rook d2 okay there Bishop is secure for
sure on b5 but I get some activity here
if the knight moves rook d2 you got
probably this right away they got to
defend their second rank like so yeah so
probably let's take the knight force
them to retreat and then play here
rook d2 difficult very active this
Bishop is maybe out of play
yeah he is I believe I'm playing with an
extra piece in this position rook d2
hitting B - G - I should have something
even Bishop to here Bishop rook d2
Bishop f6 into D for kicking a rook off
of g1 which is one of the only pieces
that could really defend g2 it's very
awkward for the knight to do that so
let's see probably have that soon
let's start with let's start with this
no let me see what's the trick here
there should be a win now let's just
take the poem I was thinking this is
unprotected after Knight d3 but I have
it defended mmm let's play here first
stop Knight d3 yeah this Knight is under
control now this is this is a nice key
move bishop here Bishop d4 will be the
winning continuation now yeah this night
is completely restricted and that should
pretty much be the ball game crashing
through on g2 now it's no squares for
the knight the bishop is out of play
he's good to secure the Queen side but
play directed towards the Kings side in
this one so let's see what they come up
with I'm not sure what more to add g2 is
collapsing these guys got to be too
strong okay so they're just giving up
their Knight I'm not sure what this
scoop is with that so just improve my
king position and that's probably other
stuff right I'm playing up a piece here
just stop there pawn from advancing and
play a little bit quicker no let's go
here take here it's probably not the
most convincing way to to do this let's
get back here actually stop any Bishop
defensive moves like this and then
retrieve Bishop to d4 and just taking
here if the pawn moves it's just a fork
here so okay I guess they're playing on
looking for like time stuff but uh
and got the increment so no worries
there I guess we'll just round up this
pawn here rook d3 here okay let's pick
up this guy and then push myseif on take
here as well so we'll see what the
computer has to say as usual after this
one you know and just play it out
sometimes and just play the games out
out of momentum so make threat here and
no stalemates making a couple thing in
one okay yeah I think I think it was the
correct decision
we'll see with again the computer but
before looking at it with the computer I
think again the decision with the
capture on c5 playing the position where
the Queen's are off and it's simplifying
a bit more I think though it was easier
to hang on to the bishop pair if if the
knight was allowed to get to e4 with the
Queen's still on board I might have felt
compelled to give up one of my bishops
but with the Queen's off it was easier
to hold on to the bishop pair and put
them to use but well we'll see what the
computer has to say and yeah we'll see
where we can make some improvements okay
let's see where there are some
improvements in this one so we had our
opponent white trying for some gambit
here
I usually decline it it's it's never
going to be the best it's not going to
be the top suggestion by the computer
but yeah I think one of the improvements
also on the white side I was referencing
the decision by me the capture on
see five but giving up that dark square
bishop probably shouldn't have done that
I can't I've done this so many times you
know playing the Carroll Khan one of the
main ideas or the the main idea is
Bishop to c5 to flying this guy but this
is it Rendon runs into some problems or
can at least you know a Queen d2
queenside castle and then these tempo
gaining moves you know with a situation
where it's opposite sides castling one
of the most influential elements in the
game will be time and you run down into
these time gaining moves you know white
launching their pawns kicking around
minor pieces threatening to trap minor
pieces and such so while he's not going
to be deployed to f5 I mean in the game
I went by way of a queen side fianchetto
at least I'm sidestepping those tempo
gaining those g4 h4g v h5 stuff so ii 6
it is queen there in fact let me go back
just a moment here and this move here
it's suggesting okay yeah just the
recapture so a slight pull for white I
guess we can expect that with their
center fourth ranked pawn versus third
ranked pawns clean there right there
yeah I already felt comfortable as soon
as the rook was playing um I thought I
thought Bishop here but in fact that's
dropping this pawn here maybe better was
Queen d2 just staying clear of this
square so that you can't connect the
Knights so this this is a bit awkward
only Knight d5 yeah it's it's an even
position so yeah they're just they're
just giving up their bishop
on Bishop back here yeah that's an
option I mean I could go in for the
damaging of the pawn structure but at
least the bishops are maintained and
white still has this pawn on e4 and it's
holding it as about an even position
okay so playing with the bishop here and
no shifts here as mentioned I don't want
to take here I'm just helping them out
helping their center helping out there
rook still has it as even but it's not
really a fun position to play as black
okay so I just went with the completing
development mm-hmm any changes here it
likes Knight d5 okay it takes f6 being
suggested okay hmm what's the story and
they takes f6 and the knight h5 oh okay
I mean it wants to go g6 so yeah I I
don't know that I would have played that
though to be perfectly honest probably
this and then Queen here ooh that's
important to be aware of Oh sneaky
converging on g7 can't play this he's
six
that's a slick move there Knight takes
Bishop takes Knight to h5 yeah I was
thinking Knight takes and then Bishop
takes Knight here but I just dropped
back and we have similar to the to the
game with the Bishop cancelling out the
knight offsetting the knight okay so
that's interesting to be aware of that
taking in the knight to h5 f4 and then
it still likes Knight d5 but anything
wrong with taking what's the
continuation 95 Queen f2 and then g6
okay so playing this position in other
words with still another minor piece on
board another night for each of us okay
yeah you know another thing these are
kind of redundant this Knight is not
playing so I'm kind of helping light out
by capturing
yeah I'm helping the piece this is
probably there this is probably their
worst fees and all of their minor pieces
at least this is the worst piece and I'm
helping them out by capturing so maybe
yeah with more time to think 95 is the
is the move to really go with and ooh f5
is still hitting huh
okay this is good to look into then
because I was expecting you know I
thought I'd be able to just do this but
apparently white is doing good here huh
ooh
with this Bishop returning here on d3
focusing on h7 and then he takes off SOT
f5 of course I want to do this
Oh even the rook and they have too many
attackers my bishop and rook are not
playing Wow +3 so this is obviously
losing here I'm just dropping the bishop
with that King h8 rook D 2 F 1 ooh
how many points do they have attacking
19 22 points and yeah not too many
defenders around here for my King in the
heart of my structure is long gone
clearly my Jeep on hmm okay so
sacrifices were working with this
advance so that said I should be doing
something other than g6 here well this
was my idea in fact I mean I wanted I
wanted to play g6 why I mean I could
have done it right now but you know I
helped out their pieces a little bit I
wanted to stop at 5 with this move
obviously and yeah it's still it's not
it's not stopping it's the tactics are
working out here giving up the night mmm
so what should I have done instead of g6
Queen c7 and then on f5 yeah I didn't
want to allow this now 5 c5 coin g4 mmm
this isn't fun to play as black
especially when the top move is King to
h8 it's not a happy day King eh eh even
dropping a pun right yeah this is no fun
so I needed to play better here at this
point Knight d5 and then g6 Queen d2 g6
now and it's not working in this case I
take
Knight takes pawn takes rook takes least
I have another piece around that could
help defend and it's suggesting Bishop
here - - and let's just give it a little
bit of time to think this one through
yeah you know here's the other thing I'm
able to play f5 and I have my dark
square bishop that's probably the main
point here the main difference I have my
dark square bishop around yeah well I
mean even in the other variation when
I'm taking here Queen takes g6 I do have
my dark square bishop in this case too
but you know I don't I don't have a
knight around that can help out with
defense it's it's not working out in
this case so important tactical shot to
be aware of both of us overlook that and
it should be fine here I don't know that
there was anything else missed no f5 is
still fitting okay you know so I guess
it's still just crashing through f5 ouch
yeah so f5 takes takes G takes rook
takes even this position huh rookie to
f1 Wow yeah even f7 is getting hit a ton
of x + - okay noted f5 is still there
this is not a sufficient defense of this
pawn push okay noted so f5 was hitting
several times a couple times and was it
hitting ever again no once I got to this
point then the tactics are calming down
a bit with the Queen's off doesn't even
like capturing on c5 here Bishop h4 okay
I'm not playing Bishop h4 that's two
that's two computer ish I guess Queen
takes Queen takes yeah he was the other
point pawn takes Knight here Bishop e7
okay still
even assha position but I want to get
the Queen's off and what else was maybe
missed here I wanted to stop before
maybe a five was unnecessary or keffe d
eight and I'm a just I'm just entering
from here just kind of plays itself out
trying to get to the second rank and
it's usually good enough to have rook on
the second rank but combined with the
pressure on G to have an additional
piece coordinating on a squid on one of
the squares on the second rank it's all
the more influential to have a rook on
the second sir if t2 takes and I'm just
getting to the second rank again but
yeah that that f5 advance okay noted g6e
six it still isn't enough these piece
Accra faces are there several instances
of sacrifices on f5 here you know my
opponent in this this one just playing
it out to its end but interesting game
hopefully some things to be taking away
from this surely I'll be more aware of
that have five advance in in ensuing
games but anyhow feel free to leave any
comments in the comment section below to
this video and as always I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye